one a soda this'll cost you more in
Philadelphia because politicians there
voted to tax these eyes a 13 amazed of
for America listen to the applause the
sugars we've never tried there was more
applause when the bill was signed the
politicians said the tax will fund early
childhood education this would be great
for this community and top a lot of
families but store owners say is a bad
tax
Melvin Robinson who runs Bruno's Pizza
says the soda tax is killing his
business what are your customers say
what'd they say they're not buying it I
refuse to buy soda in Philadelphia
well 29 so almost 3,000 so instead of
buying at Bruno's they cross the street
because Bruno's is located right on the
outer edge of filling so I gotta get a
soda or a juice I'll go
right
[Music]
I want something to drink I go right
there but he comes here for the pizza
yeah yeah you got the best slicing down
but the soda tax still punishes Melvin
this happens whenever local governments
impose special new taxes like who should
pay three dollars for a drink that they
used to get for 99 cents if customers
can escape they will do the politicians
think about that so a buck war one of
these it definitely is more but it's for
what we feel are good is a good reason
for a good cause
City Councilman William Greenlee says
Philadelphia needs the tax money nothing
else that we could come up with could
raise that kind of that kind of funding
but soda taxes were disproportionately
paid by poor people even so-called
progressives campaigned against this tax
you don't have the funds I'll care on
the backs of the poorest people in this
city that's a regressive way to raise
funds it hits the poor most what Bernie
Sanders opposes this I didn't know
Bernie opposed it but okay remember
we're raising enough money to put twenty
seven hundred kids in in pre-k and to
open 11 community schools the pizza
parlors
customers didn't think their taxes were
being well-spent preschool I doubt that
very much
the mayor says he's helping people he
ain't helping me he's Tamia meanwhile
taxes create unintended consequences
soda sales are way down but sales of
more harmful products are up now some
people are buying a little more liquor
less coke more liquor I don't know about
that because we have a liquor tax to
politicians love taxes on unhealthy
things and sort of the media they
applauded when Denmark tax fatty food
Denmark has decided to implement what
they're calling it tax basically you go
to the supermarket you buy a food that
has above a certain level of fat they
charge you extra all right do we feel
good about this Vasil Italy but Danes
just crossed the border to shop another
country within a year Denmark repealed
its FAFSA but Philadelphia isn't
repealing anything people this town
already pay for T for Texas state income
tax sales tax cigarette and alcohol
taxes Philadelphia has a very high
income tax compared to other places how
can you not have enough money the wage
tax good money and that no I don't know
about that but there's a lot to do out
there job 4 million for the Office of
Arts and Culture mm-hmm
funded two sessions of dance instruction
teach youth empowerment social issues
through hip hop office arts and culture
does a very good job in the city of
Philadelphia like we need that right we
need it they're funding the arts we're
arts people trying to live politician
says we got to raise money stop stealing
that would be nice I don't know that
he's stealing but he pays himself 121
thousand bucks a year Wow
you making 121 thousand a year three
times what the median income what your
citizens make well I don't think that's
terribly unusual for elected officials
sadly he's right politicians routinely
make much more than the people they
allegedly surf a lot of citizens should
make more money you know I'm well they
can't make more money when your taxes
the death I don't think we're taxing him
to death the politicians always want
more and the restaurants they just have
to pay
you